if you didn't now I have had two great
love's in my life doing what I do here
and the real estate business I love real
estate mom and dad were in the real
estate business when I was growing up
and three weeks after I turned 18 years
old I sat for and passed my real estate
license a few weeks later I sold my
first house as a real estate agent what
that tells you is somebody out there had
a like a judgment they bought a house
from an eighteen year old but even then
I knew how to sell apparently at some
level so you know I've always loved real
estate I love the business I love the
people in the business it's a new it's a
unique group of individuals the real
estate business is the only business
where people put glamor shots on their
business card I mean it these are drama
queens so they have a blast real estate
people are fun that when they're at an
event they're that it's a fun group to
talk to because they're enthusiastic
they're fired up there it's just cool
and so I always enjoy sending great real
estate agents across America and our ELP
program you know sending you to them to
find your next home or to you know get
your house listed and get it sold for
the proper amount of money not giving it
away especially in a hot market like
this and so I just love the business and
then you know some folks in that
business don't like me because I tell
people not to buy a house until you're
ready because when people buy a house
when they're broke it makes them broker
that's why they call them mortgage
brokers broker and broker you buy a
house you're broke you're not ready it's
a curse it's not a blessing
I want your home to be a blessing but
we've passed this piece of
misinformation around in our culture
that says everyone ought to buy a house
and if you buy a house is gonna make all
your financial problems go away the only
way that little men can get ahead is buy
a house he can't afford
she's a bunch of crap you shouldn't buy
a house when you're broke
so I want everybody get a house because
I don't everybody get out of being broke
but when you buy outs and you're broke
all kinds of crap loot turns loose in
your life when you're in debt you don't
have any money use your last dime for
your down payment but you buy a house my
house my house my house gotta buy a
house got it my house got my house got
it buy a house we don't buy a house all
renting you just throwing your money
away my house my house my house my house
my house
oh the payments the same as the rent so
my house my house my house my house my
house and everybody goes and buys a
house that can't afford and if enough
broke people buy houses you can crash
the economy y'all know that was a
reference to 2008 that was 2008 joke
y'all with me here if enough broke
people buy a house you can crash the
economy with this wrong philosophy of
everybody needs a house everybody should
get a house cuz I want everybody to get
away from being broke so they can afford
a house so get out of debt get your
emergency fund in place but if you buy a
house and you don't do that Murphy will
move in your spare bedroom if you're in
debt you buy a house broke he'll move in
your spare bedroom you know Murphy is if
I can go wrong it well he'll bring his
three cousins broke desperate and stupid
with him and your hot water oh go out
the next week and your roof will leak
three days later and then the heating
air will go down
Oh in the sewer will stop up for the
septic tank will back up I mean you're
gonna find out the joys of homeownership
when you move in the house broke you are
asking for trouble you're begging for it
so get yourself straight get out of that
get the emergency fund in place and then
start saving for your down payment that
we call that baby step 3b because you're
after baby step three and you haven't
yet started baby step four with your
retirement savings because you're gonna
save up for a down payment on your house
then when you get ready to buy a house
want to put as much down as you can put
down if you put down 20% it'd be ideal
because you can avoid PMI private
mortgage insurance which is merely
foreclosure insurance that if you get
foreclosed on it pays the mortgage
company if they lose money on you if you
put down 20% you don't have to buy PMI
which is useless to you it's a favor you
do the insurer you do for the mortgage
company because you didn't put down
enough down payment you put down 20% you
avoid that it's about $75 a month per
hundred thousand borrowed one hundred
fifty bucks a month for two hundred
thousand our mortgage for PMI so
like for you to put down more than that
no yell at you if you don't but I will
yell at you if you violate this next one
never buy a house on more than a 15 year
mortgage absolutely crazy don't do that
don't do it don't buy a house on more
than a 15 year mortgage and never buy a
house on a 15-year fixed-rate where the
payment is more than 1/4 of your
take-home pay now you got keep in mind
interest rates are what 3 percent you
know most of the time interest rates
have been 10 12 percent in my working
lifetime but for the last decade or so
we've had these ridiculously wonderfully
low interest rates and so you know if
you can't afford to do it right now
you're not gonna be able to afford to do
it right ever so right is you know 15 to
20 percent down hopefully a 15-year
fixed where the payments no more than
1/4 of your take-home pay so if you're
in the market to buy a house you don't
buy your largest purchase in the scope
of your lifetime on a motion yeah that's
the last thing you need impulse is
something this size adults devise a plan
and follow it children do what feels
good be a grown-up if you're gonna be
growing up and buy a house be growing up
emotionally slow down do it right
and jump on Dave Ramsey calm we got a
free completely free mortgage calculator
there you want to your mortgage
calculations is right there we just re
vamped the thing it's slick it's the
best one out there
matter of fact it's trending is one of
the best mortgage calculators on Google
right now so just go to Dave Ramsey com
click on the mortgage calculator and you
can figure out what you can do with the
private mortgage insurance on a $200,000
home how much it saves you a few other
things to keep in mind in the home
buying process in a hot market you may
need to move further out of the city in
order to get a price you can afford so
you may be training homeownership for a
commute closer to the city in most
markets the more expensive it gets now
certain distance from cities that starts
to become a neighborhood issue
but I'm saying if you move 30 minutes
out of town my County over those are
sometimes called bedroom communities
then that puts you in a place to do it
the right kind of stuff if you'll get a
high-octane real estate agent they will
help you with your selection they'll
represent you as a buyer's agent or if
you're getting ready to sell a house get
a real estate agent in your corner that
knows what they're doing
this is someone that has a lot of volume
they sell 50 200 houses a year not 5,200
that houses in their lifetime so do this
right I mean if you make a 5% mistake on
a $200,000 transaction that's a $10,000
ouchy because you were too smudged you
could do it yourself you don't work on
your $20,000 car by yourself why would
you work on your $200,000 house by
yourself I'm dumb so get a pro in your
corner our real estate help ease to the
pros we recommend just click on Dave
Ramsey comm run the Dave Ramsey comm get
your mortgage calculator this is a great
real estate market you guys it's a fun
time to be selling a fun time to be
looking for properties real estates just
fun y'all it's just fun it's not fun
when you're broke and you do it wrong so
do it right and we will enjoy the ride
together this is the Dave Ramsey show